[Musique]
si vous voulez le hasard surgi en force
à l'issue de votre copine je savais pas
ce que tu me dis parce que la trace et
andorre 2 n'est possible que dans les
systèmes ou à l équilibre
oui chéri c'est moi tu vas bien tu as
fait bon voyage
je suis pour voyage à cherry qu'est-ce
que je suis content de temps en temps tu
sais je t'aime je pense à toi sans art
aussi je pense à toi sans arrêt tu mama
tu me manques que celui-ci est ce que tu
fais en ce moment chez pour ce moment je
suis en train de regarder les photos de
toi et des critiques chez aux portes et
ne me dis pas tu emporte une photo de
moi et des enfants oui tu es merveilleux
tu me reprocher j'ai tout de suite eu à
moi j'ai une surprise pour tous il fait
surpris tu chéris j'ai mes grands mères
dans tera 10 $ et oui chérie j'ai mes
grands mères dans ta valise sale petit
cochon ordures c'est le marché des
sexuelle
bonjour s de grands dégueulasse mines
il ya une liaison étroite entre
l'aléatoire et irréversible invité de ce
magazine d ar pieri car aviateurs
artisans il vient de réaliser son
premier film thierry car mon jour
pourquoi film sur les ulm donc quand
j'ai fini car vous êtes empêcher un
passionné des ulm
ça ne date pas d'hier cette élection il
a écouté le mieux je crois c'est
peut-être qu'on voit en images ce que
vous avez réalisé un petit extrait tout
de suite du film de pierre ricard une
bud peuple-belge une journée que qq qui
se sont déroulés coupe ce qui est beau
film le coucou coucou on prend on a fait
comme ça y est tout le monde tout le
monde je vous remercie de votre
attention
à demain la semaine prochaine les amours
célèbres ou la véritable histoire
d'amour du lys et de pénélope
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tunis 30 ans de son long périple n'avait
dans ses oreilles que le chant des
sirènes
si votre femme vous emmerde
faites comme moi fait le coup des
sirènes c'est facile et ça marche à tous
les coups
[Musique]
c'est du maurice vraiment vous n'avez
rien monsieur que vous déjà été formulée
la peine peut l'être fait chaud oui nom
prénom âge et dernier emploi alors fait
chaud violette chocolat 22 ans
vous mettez 22 ans ahmed dernier un peu
péripatéticienne en trois mots
péripatéticienne dans notre secteur
alors là il n'y a plus rien le marché
complètement saturé n'ont rien du tout
où étiez-vous j'ai fait sur les grands
boulevards j'avais une très très bonne
petite clientèle je me faisais très bon
mois non j'ai rien du tout ça fait
combien de temps que vous avez arrêté de
travailler
ça fait un petit mois quoi au juste vous
avez dû perdre la main a pas du tout à
ça j'ai pas perdu la main monsieur pulga
entre nous j'ai travaillé au noir génial
on ne parle pas de racisme ici on a des
pe
tout le monde a droit au travail j'ai
rien rue
non tout est bloqué là j'ai peut-être un
truc la rue car banal dans le quartier
des fonctionnaires à la carte et les
fonctionnaires quelle horreur monsieur
j'ai commencé au quartier des
fonctionnaires j'estime qu'à l'heure
actuelle je tue devenue une
professionnelle une méritante et je
tiens à évoluer dans mon travail c'est
pas la peine de regarder géré ian lauzon
je suis désolé s'en prennent à suez des
mois donc je vous en prie faites un
petit effort et des mois oui c'est mais
le voyage
oui je suis prête à déménager s'il le
faut je peux peut-être vous aider j'ai
mon frère nos frères a déjà fait pas mal
de choses pour certaines de vos
collègues
c'est formidable moyennant une
commission je suis prête à tout on
espère il est dans les parages on espère
bien voir ici
c'est la nouvelle pour tanger mois pour
avoir de beaux cheveux
j'utilise mejor major est un shampoing
100% naturel fait à base de guano
d'excréments de poule
mais je dors h emploie 100 % naturel la
dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents la
princesse nadine amouk et le prince lui
victime des sortilèges de merlin le
chanteur cherche une solution pour
retrouver leur apparence normale je peux
pas rester comme ça bouge pas on va les
vérifier
t'es foutu je crois que c'est fermé le
mardi c'était bien nous a quand même
essayé samedi ma mère est là rien n'a
rien
mesdemoiselles
nous allons aujourd'hui aborder la leçon
27 chapitres 49/100 les doigts de ton et
maman soit propre
je compte sur votre vigilance le
syndicat a toujours raison le syndicat a
toujours raison qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous savez pas lire
c'est fermé le mardi
il faut toujours obéir aux syndicats
contenu vous nous écoutez une crotte
il ne faut pas oublier de payer ses
cotisations au syndicat ni pour vos
ridules payer ses cotisations syndicales
et paulino reset ces thèmes où vous me
reprenait tout ça plus fort s'il vous
plaît il ne faut pas pauline il ne faut
pas payer ses cotisations au syndicat du
silence on veut retrouver notre
apparence à vous voulez transformer au
oui oui transformer nous allez les
filles le sens vannes chaque chapitre 42
ce qui donnerait pas qu'elle l'ait fait
exprès je les connais
[Musique]
monsieur charles bricolo un des chefs de
l'opposition nationale n'y va pas de
main morte
lors du dernier congrès de son parti
il accuse notre corporation de
complaisance voire de complicité totale
vis-à-vis du pouvoir en place
eh bien monsieur charles tricot l'eau
puisque vous accuser directement notre
rédaction
je vais vous répondre au nom de tous mes
confrères nous nous les journalistes de
gauche
nous savons ce qu'est l'objectivité nous
savons ce qu'est l'indépendance d'esprit
indépendance objectivité de vous ignorer
complètement vous hein vous la droite a
pointé par le comité des forges et les
nervis de la cia mort mon run hervy
fasciste non au grand capital
vive l'indépendance d'esprit vive la
liberté de la presse vive la gauche unie
vive monsieur le ministre de
l'information
nous avons le pouvoir et nous le
garderons
[Musique]
dans son
mais là
moi depuis cinq ans j'ai tous deux
savent au monde ou presque le savons et
nous je le trouve plutôt gourmande beaux
lots 6 à la pause
ça fait dix ans ça fait dix ans que je
travaille à l'usiné de savon mon minou
et je peux vous assurer et collez les
savons mon minou sont vraiment des
savons pur chat en plus il est 100% pur
cher
[Musique]
faire du cinéma c'est à la portée de
tous
tout dépend évidemment de la direction
d'acteurs par exemple le dialogue entre
ces deux personnages as-tu pensé à
acheter le pain oui mais j'ai oublié de
prendre le sel c'est tout chéri que la
charcuterie d'à côté fermé non c'est
dommage le boudin il était très bon on
peut prendre des formes diverses selon
le metteur en scène à la manière de cluj
[Musique]
oui je vais prendre le sel en fait c'est
tu chéris que la charcuterie d'à côté
fermé c'est dommage le boudry ne
[Musique]
pensez à acheter le pain mais je pense
acheter le pain mais j'ai complètement
oublié de prendre celle du shérif que
l'achat petite fille d'à côté le projet
à la manière de jean luc godard dû
penser à prendre le bain oui mais j'ai
oublié de prendre le cerf au fait tu
sais tu que la charcuterie d'à côté
fermé c'est dommage mais voudrait
tellement
achetez-vous bah oui
j'ai oublié de prendre le sel
[Musique]
et vous
en fait la charcuterie d'à côté fermé
[Musique]
le good eye été bon
as-tu pensé l'attendre le point pris
mais j'ai oublié de prendre le sel à à
ces petits chéris que ma chérie currie
des territoriaux comme le bouddha
étaient si bons
[Musique]
à
tu as pensé comme le satellite ka
chapitre il ajouté personnellement j'ai
cette version là qu'on préfère
[Musique]
n'hésitez pas à nous écrire dit fr3 à
marseille 2 à l'airé grassi 13008
marseille on tiendra compte de vos
réactions
peut-être
[Musique]